people dming me like Gary I need your
help I'm Shadow banned then I click
their account and look at their content
I'm like ah got it go back to the DM hey
brother you're not Shadow banned you
just
suck everybody here wants to blame the
algorithm how about getting better at it
and better at it means knowing how to
title your videos what the thumbnail
needs to look like what the first three
seconds should look like the copy that
you support it with what time you post
it how you engage in the comments and
what are the platform differences of a
carousel versus a res versus a straight
post and having a hook and like how
about realizing this is a skill instead
of dumb [__] luck and what about
putting in the hours of reading and
testing and working to be good at
it